[Music]
greg here i'm stuck in new jersey it's a
hell hole i was wondering what youtubers
thought about all these flights being
canceled all over the holidays it
sucks thanks for nothing have a good one
kind of aggressive hey what was his
favorite name
explain these days here's the thing
gregory
you got it you gotta go with the safety
guys the safety guys know what their
figures talking about we got some
problems people breathing on top of
other mothers you gotta keep your mask
on you're drinking white wine take your
mask off you finish your white wine put
the smash back on craig those are the
rules i said you're eating strawberries
or some stairs you take a strawberry
print a mask on you you get another
strawberry take it off again that's how
it works greg why get yourself a cup of
tears coffee when you're in the airport
that's fine get a cup of coffee it's
going to cost you three or four dollars
you get the money it's gonna cost you
four or five dollars these days yes
cheers in the airport maybe seven or
eight dollars because your fingers
putting you over up there
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me back all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your oyster baby you're my pearl